this morning on the dish a chef known
worldwide for his inventive take on
Indian cuisine growing up in Mumbai
Floyd Cardoz planned on a medical career
until a love of food put him on a
different path after attending hotel
management schools in India and Europe
he headed to New York and made his name
with the highly acclaimed modern Indian
restaurant table his newest venues span
the globe pow wala offers casual modern
Indian in New York so Howe and the
Bombay Cantina in Mumbai brings his
unique take on the cooking of his
homeland back to where it all began
chef Floyd Cardos welcome to the dish
thank you for having me tell us about
this fantastic spread so we're gonna
start you over the cocktail one of my
favorites on a menu called Johnny be
good which is Black Label Scotch with
honey and coconut water a bit of light
it's very handsome it's very and very
very delicious and then we're gonna
start you off with sweet potato chart
which is roasted sweet potatoes with
tamarind and chilies and mint followed
by our shrimp curry which is something
my grandmom used to make with Naomi and
then we have a choice making biryani
this was made public
again biryani my father's mother and
something I'd always remember making
which is rice and chorizo which is the
Portuguese sausage
yeah adapted by Goa followed by our
broccoli with lime and chili and to end
we have one of my favorite fruits as a
grilled pineapple with a honey syrup
this is we you mentioned Portugal and
Portuguese cuisine when people think of
Indian food I think they have a kind of
a monochromatic sense of it but in fact
the food of Carol of Goa is influenced
very much by European cuisine tell us
more about it so the Portuguese were in
India for over 300 years which most
people don't realize they were they were
my restaurants called pas Walla and Pao
is the bread that the Portuguese bought
to India which is now all over India
yeah
but they came in the influence that's
with wok with vinegar you know they
bought the tamarind then they bought all
these things into India that now people
eat regularly the English and the
British were there for a long time the
French were in the south of India Kerala
and they bought the you know their
cooking techniques to India so we've had
colonisation for a long time but the
Portuguese
I follow that line in the late 1950s in
the food as much as you love food
growing up you had you were intending in
a completely different direction yeah I
was actually I was in the sciences you
wanted to be a doctor I want to be a
doctor I wanted to be a biochemist and I
read a book called out it's called hot
del hotel by Arthur Haley Haley yeah and
when I read that book I was like wow
this is so much fun because I love food
growing up food was a big part of my
life and I said oh I could go work in a
hotel I could be in hospitality I could
eat whatever food I want and then I
started cooking and realized that I was
really good at it yeah and I was like
wow I'm really good at this maybe I
should stand this well but in India
traditionally women are the ones who
cook and you were on track to become a
doctor how difficult was it to leap into
a role that isn't necessarily lauded in
the same way in Indian culture it was it
was very very hard because when I went
into the into the business and I worked
in the kitchens
I was working 6 days a week 14 to 16
hours a day I lost all my friends hang
out with a cook so that was that was
really hard so that's when I realized
that you know what India was not for me
you had to leave I had to leave yeah so
I went to Switzerland I studied in
Switzerland my brother tried to bring me
to the United States he used to come in
you came here for a wedding in the end I
can't finally convince me to come for a
wedding and I came gave my days myself a
date saying okay if I don't get my job
I'm gonna leave and go back a day before
I was supposed to go back I got a job
and you introduced Indian food to New
Yorkers in a way that they've never
really tasted it before how difficult
was it you now have a restaurant back in
India how difficult was it to go back
home again so I never want to do an
Indian restaurant because I found that
the Indian food in the late eighties
early 90s in New York wasn't very good
it was the same restaurant North Indian
food that most of us didn't eat I like
to say India is like Europe yeah and you
can't say European cuisine but I say
Italian cuisine and Spanish cuisine and
French cuisine and everybody's very
different so going back to India and
bringing this back was very important to
me but I realize that New York to need
of this chef as I asked you to
as his custom I'll ask you if you could
share this meal with any figure past or
present who would it be so I would
actually like to share this meal with a
fictitious family there is a book called
100 foot journey
okay and it's made into a movie yeah I
did the food for the movie it's a great
movie and the chef in that book Hassan
his story is very similar to mine so I
would like to see what his inspirations
are how he feels my food I love this
idea yeah jumping into a parallel
universe
Floyd Cardoz creative to the end thank
you and good luck with a new restaurant
thank you
for more on chef Cardos and the dish
head to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com